what do you think about amber heard
casey she's a liar man like you could
even tell through the bad acting there
was one tick tock that i saw yeah when
she was like even using excuse that her
dog stepped and stepped on her
yeah like what is that
why is that relevant within a court case
you understand but um i feel like she's
trying to use her image as a
it's as mad as a woman to try and go
against um johnny depp
but we're not falling for it i feel like
people so i feel like people walked
about the situation that we're not going
to fall for that that easily
yeah well what do you think about uh
johnny though have you ever been
watching it
i've seen i've seen a couple things
um
i just think
you know that's a representation of a
of a
terrible terrible terrible woman that's
all i can really say on it i haven't
seen too much on it
yeah
that's really that's how i feel about it
have you have you guys as as guys
because you know the lasers spoken have
you guys seen any representations in
your personal life or in someone else's
personal life of what you would call
toxic femininity
gonna go first oh yeah a hundred percent
hundred percent i see people
maybe use you know they're using the
advantage but to be honest when i was
hearing the conversation the problem
with the toxic muscle um the toxic
femininity is that it's a lot of givens
from the men
when you guys do your job as
you know you're like you were saying we
then give
that's the problem with it what do you
mean as in to say that we
we we're the ones that provide their
attention and provide you know when we
go we're talking about clubs when we go
to the club yeah girls ain't paying for
nothing in the clubs right so i'm saying
so are you
are you saying we are we flew like are
we giving them that opportunity though
no you feel like are you feeding the
female ego is that what it is [ __ ] guys
are feeding the females
certain there's certain people that are
definitely feeding it like i mean i
don't know me myself i am feeding
i ain't feeding no woman nothing but
i mean
i mean
but um
yeah man the female ego gets fed a lot
by too many guys that's the problem yeah
but you can't really say that because
you never know it's like you meet him in
now you don't know if you're feeding my
ego or not so you can't really just
you never you're never aware because you
can meet someone and to them like that's
you meeting them and that's them getting
a compliment throughout that week that's
not you feeding their ego no but i know
when i'm feeding someone's ego because
if i'm doing it i'm doing
how do you know if you don't mind me
asking because if i know if i'm doing
i'm doing it on purpose doing what
exactly does feeding the eagles yeah but
you buy me a drink don't mean you're
feeding me my ego what like you buy me a
drink you buy okay call fax remove what
next all right cool i'm not feeding your
ego on purpose but as in i know it will
and that will be a result of what that
my action will be to buy your dream you
can't say you buy me a drink is
specifically feeding my ego per se okay
because you can't say to me that's a
drink i go out regularly and i get a
drink from people just get me a drink
that's just my normal now so to me
that's not if you get what i'm trying to
come from i don't see that as feeling
the ego and in terms of saying that i
feel like when it comes to female you
don't you can't say you're i get it to a
certain degree yeah you can tell when
you are feeding some but not with all
that's what i'm trying to say
if the roles weren't reversed wouldn't
you feel the same
would you um give me an example so like
if like instead of men moving to women
like you know in the club or whatever
buying them drinks women did that to men
would you not feel an ego boost
of course that's what i'm saying that's
why i feel like it is that not all women
have that but some do get the ego boost
out of it which is fair enough it's so
com it makes them feel good about
themselves about their opinion so you're
saying as a man if a woman was to buy
you a drink you would get an ego beast
wait hold on wait wait no no we're
talking
i'm talking
like
the attention that i received from that
i will it will be it will be my job to
then give an eagle boost back to you i'm
trying to say i think i more meant if it
was more like the norm for girls to do
that to guys instead of guys to do it to
girls
so it was acceptable for him to get an
ego boost from a girl buying him drinks
all night or it depends the way then
that would that was what she does but
the thing is that would be like that
would mean a a complete flip of rosin
wouldn't it yeah
that would be like men
women being men you know what i'm saying
like that um you would get an ego boost
out of it there's nothing wrong with it
like i mean if a woman comes to you and
says obviously that's what i'm saying it
depends the way you do it because if you
come you know sweeten me up a little bit
and just say
you're looking because i was then
obviously i'm gonna
it's my job to then respond to that in
the in the way that is suitable because
i can't be like oh you know i want to be
like okay nah you know what i see what
you're going to do
i see what you're done there but babes
what's your drink that you're about to
buy me that's the one that you want all
right let's get two of those but come on
they gotta be on me that's the kind of
way but that's what you're giving us
free games right you're not freaked out
you just helped us so you're like you're
saying you have to do this go to a guy
who said you you
it's not really to do with the pride
it's really
no it is to be honest
you think you're setting yourself down
because we're offering you a drink
speaking
but then now you're saying like because
we've offered you a drink you're like no
don't worry you can't be buying me a
drink i'll buy you one and buy for
myself too no but the delivery is very
important
because i might even let you buy me the
one but then the rest of them i feel
like you are too big-headed especially
if i come to you within your boys i'm
like let me buy you a drink what do you
mean let me buy you a drink yeah do you
guys say you're not going to he's going
to be like nice right you seem like a
woman now like she seems like the man
and you seem
like that's what it would be like yeah
do you know what i mean if i do that in
front of your boys you're just like nah
let's not do that yeah you're going to
want to patent it as quickly as possible
no but let's okay let's be real a.d
if a girl comes up to us in the club and
one of them says i want to buy you a
drink the real conversation maybe that's
what we give you but if we're talking
honestly the real conversation but if
she she's really rather buying me a
drink you know what that means i'mma buy
her the next few do let's go from there
let's be real fair enough that's as real
as it gets though okay so the
conversation i'm having with like or i
know guys would have is oh
what you men want to drink too i might
ask if she'd go and get you something if
she's never happening
let me finish the reason why i'm doing
that is because more so than anything if
a girl's moving to me in the club i'm
confused like
this is masculine energy i'm not on that
that's why i think that i've got this
feminine energy that you've had the
courage to approach me like that's
correct so more so i'm like okay cool
like if this is how you're moving oh
let's run game but that's probably how
far i go but then that's part of the way
she approached you or just approaching
you in general but the thing is there's
a way in which women can let men know
the way is it is it her asking you for a
drink or is it the way she's asked you
for a drink it's the way she's asking me
for a drink okay so if i come to like
you know
i think you look good
and just a nice little nice one sweet
tone and say can i just i'm gonna be
taking her back because i'm just asking
that's that in what way is that is it
just her asking in general or is it just
so as sorrow's about to say i think he's
about here it's the way women ask if a
woman a woman
in history have moved to men but the way
a woman would move to a man is they
would she would drop her handkerchief
and yeah she would look like oh my god i
need help
and then allow the man to to make the
move right now if you as a woman don't
have the success to be able to make that
happen or do that then
yo like i'm looking at you i'm thinking
okay like there's a lot of masculine
energy in here and this could fester in
the future yeah like in ways that we
won't are not we can't see right men
respond to peacocking right so
peacocking is like i don't you've seen a
peacock when they spread their their
their their tails
oh [ __ ] yeah that that's what men
respond to generally and women do that
every day by wearing nice dresses by
wearing shoes by
looking nice by doing their hair right
men see something that looks nice and
they respond to it and then they go
towards it do you get what i'm saying so
we do that in everyday life so if a
woman that's a peacock
comes to a man
he's like um
i'm supposed to be doing that right i'm
supposed to be coming up to you that's
just me and maybe it's because
especially that now like women have like
the confidence they don't see as
masculine it's just like you're taking
too long or something where i genuinely
do want to approach you it's not going
to come across like if i'm approaching
i'm not going to come across yo give me
your number it's a bit it's a bit too
much but it's a way where it would be a
softer turn it'd be a conversation and
it wouldn't be more of a
aggressiveness kind of thing i would
thought like people are more open to
that nowadays because do you find men do
you find men are more open to women
approaching them like a little bit more
laid back now yeah so they don't mind
where they come from the way you're
saying it like is
girls girls are just doing what the
girls are doing and then the man if the
man likes you comes to you but i feel
like nowadays i don't know because when
you go into these spaces on the internet
when the man are saying oh yeah no like
be a bit more active like come up to me
say something show me
i'm in that safe space seeing that so
now i've come to you to come and push
because i've been taught i should
approach guys now you're looking at me
like we have to buy my whole my whole
team would drop i don't know
look i'll explain that to you so like in
the short term
that is conducive that works women
moving to men
like an exchange of attention for sex
essentially
works amazing like it's exactly what the
guy wants long term
that guy is not going to commit to you
let me tell you something about me i
initiated the it's meant
it's not just that you initiated it's
more so that he didn't pick you
that's right as a guy it's it's as a
leader it should be that he
chooses you yeah
if men
yeah
i said this yesterday on the show
men will happily have sex with a
masculine woman
happiness
yeah i meant i said a man will have sex
with a hole in the wall
not
that masculine energy that woman
displayed is going to be a problem
within a relationship
because men don't want to know that
they're in a relationship with a
masculine woman they want a feminine
woman so they want to know that they
chose a woman
right
and then she's their woman that they
chose he doesn't want to feel like
yeah she chose me so i'm just here